um so ninety years later they're once
again printing their own wooden dollars
to pass out to members of the community
[Music]
everyone this is Zach here with Mike
waters he's our newest writer at the
hustle and Michael this week you wrote a
really interesting Sunday story about
this small town in Washington that
created its own currency tell me a
little bit about this place and why they
started doing this yeah so the town is
called to 9 o laughington it's out in
the woods it was known as like this big
lumber hub in the early 1900s and one of
its claims to fame in the world and
especially in the u.s. is the fact that
during the Great Depression it had
started its own currency and they
printed be sort of like fake dollar
bills that were on slick thin wooden
blocks and they pass it out to members
of the community in the early 1930s
after one of their only town banks
closed down and so people were out of
money people were desperate and so they
basically started up their own currency
back in the 1930s and it was a huge hit
to the point where people still collect
these like wooden to nine o dollars that
are not like legal currency in the
federal sense and now though I mean
we're facing another unprecedented like
economic catastrophe this town they know
their history very well in the mayor of
this town is basically trying to bring
back that program for 2020 so ninety
years later they're once again printing
their own wooden dollars to pass out to
them to the community and they were even
using like the same reason like a
hundred and thirty year old printer as
their mint right yeah yeah in the 1930s
it was originally printed on this like
newspaper printer from 1890 so even then
it was kind of old and and they're using
the same exact mint right now to print
their currency basically and one reason
for that is just the like historical
value and the other reason is like even
the
best forger is probably not gonna do a
great job of forging something printed
like on an 1890 newspaper printer so
it's a little proof so they're starting
with a first printing of around $10,000
what's kind of their general plan for
for distributing this what's their
vision and who is he gonna help exactly
yeah so this money again is gonna be
distributed not using like US federal
dollars but using this like own local
wooden currency so the idea behind that
first of all is that because this
currency only is really like accepted in
tune I know you can't go off spending
that money anywhere like Amazon is not
gonna take your wooden dollars from
tonight oh so it's a way to keep the
money local and they are targeting
especially with this initial ten
thousand dollar printing they're
targeting low-income residents who've
been affected by the pandemic so to
qualify you have to prove that you're
below the poverty line and that you've
been affected in some way by these last
few months um and they're pretty they're
pretty open to how that latter part of
like whether you've been affected is
defined and so if you qualify you get a
stipend from within the ten thousand
dollars and I should also I should also
clarify here that this is a town of like
eighteen hundred people so ten thousand
dollars does go a long way and if it's
only targeting a certain population
within this community um so although it
might not seem much on the scale of a
larger city it does mean a lot in a town
like this and yeah and basically every
business in town is locally run and so
almost every business has signed up to
accept this money and so people who are
given out the wooden dollars can spend
it anywhere in town and like I said
because it's not official US dollars
it's a way to ensure that the money
stays local in is boosting local
businesses who have also been impacted
by the pandemic
sure so it's got this kind of twofold
effect of helping these businesses that
have kind of been beleaguered by the
pandemic but also helping provide some
kind of recourse for low-income
residents right exactly and um you also
touched on on a number of other you
found tons of examples of other towns
doing this internationally which which I
thought were really interesting what
what is the is this something that might
be used in effectively in other towns
like I know there's been a little bit of
research done on on the effectiveness of
local currencies you touch on that a
little bit yeah um the research as it
stands is a little bit complicated
it is really hard to find like exact
cause and effects with something like
this because there's so many factors at
play it's hard to measure exactly to
what extent local currencies like this
help economic recoveries which is
especially what they were designed for
but the evidence from research see it
seems to be cautiously positive ID
probably summarize it which is to say
that there are in about like half of the
cases there are signs that local
currencies have some sort of positive
impact on local businesses and on
getting people spending and then another
half of cases according to one study are
kind of inconclusive and it's certainly
something that has worked in different
places more than others around the world
there are plenty of stories especially
from the great depression of local
currencies like dramatically cutting
jobless rates in a certain region while
like in the larger country for instance
jobless rates might go up and so I mean
again it's it's hard to tease out
exactly links sometimes but there's
plenty of evidence the evidence is
like I said cautiously positive I would
say sure sure well this is a really
interesting story and if you guys want
to read it be sure to check out our
email on Sunday thanks a lot Michael
preciate your time yeah thank you
[Music]
[Applause]